The answer is that vertical lines cannot be written in this form. Remember that
the slopes of vertical lines are undefined. Because as we saw earlier, when we
try to calculate the change in x in order to find the slope, we end up with a
denominator of zero. And dividing by zero does not give us defined answers. Or
in other words, answers that are numbers that we can work with. Since we can't
come up with a number to represent m, we can't write vertical lines in this
form. Furthermore, since vertical lines are parallel to the y-axis, they will
never intersect it. That means that we can't find a value for b in this form of
the equation either. Vertical lines, therefore, do not have y intercepts, and
have undefined slopes. Which makes it impossible for us to write it in this form
that involves slopes and y intercept's.